What an interesting thing to say out loud.
This is what we call the Madonna whore complex.
That there are only two things a woman can be.
A pure, innocent,
virginal, virtuous woman, or a whore.
Cause the funny thing is, men have this value system for women.
Women, unless they are still very much engaged in the patriarchy
and in their own internal misogyny,
have gotten beyond that
to recognize that a pornstar is nothing but an entrepreneur.
And why would I,
as a non pornstar woman,
give a shit
if a man is looking to date or marry someone who's a sex worker?
Why would that matter?
To me, it just means we don't have the same like, life ideas and goals.
Like, I'm not gonna become a pornstar because a man wants a pornstar,
just as much as a woman is not gonna become a trad wife
because a man wants a trad wife.
There's no inherent morality in one or the other.
Both literally are just fantasies made up by men for men.
Because real women fall somewhere in the gray area of just general
whole identity.
You see, as a traditional housewife,
I can still throw it down, honey.
I'm very open with my sexuality.
I don't find that a counterpoint to me being a good wife and mother
and housekeeper.
Just as I'm sure there are sex workers and former sex workers
who make fabulous housewives,
devoted partners and incredible parents.
But what I Find really interesting is the only,
I guess, equivalent term we have for men is F boy.
And no one has ever suggested that an f boy wouldn't
eventually make a father and husband,
whether or not he is a good one.
But, like, these aren't the only options for women.